2 there
are several ways to search pubmed
by journal you can search by the
full journal title the
international standard serial number or
there is is is in or by the
journal title abbreviation medline note that when
using only a partial journal title
journal will not get the best
results from pop med let's try a
search for the journal of pediatrics
order and on pubmed click search
your results will include all citations
from this paper journal you
may want to sort
results by most recent for this
type
Click the most recent sort button
if the journal title is also a
subject term such as cancer or
pediatrics or if you are unsure of the
exact journal title use advanced
search to avoid
journal search issues  in the
search builder section
select journal
enter several characters of the
journal name in the search box
select the title  ulo of the journal from the
autocomplete menu
click on off to add the journal
to the query box
click on search to find all
the pubmed works of this journal